so we have his final displacement
right I'm going to again take it to the
to the neutral Y where it doesn't do
anything
okay I'm ten I neutral and
then go around the hand
Ander
neutral
young
project then around the
hand neutral y project around the
hand
neutral on or just dice project
underneath his
center around the hand
energy
neutral y
for okay I'll explain it because if it's
not obvious to all all you here it's not
obvious to the dors online okay so this
is push up and go to neutral
y there nothing here it's just like
where we started okay only he's not
exactly in the same position nor am I
okay so I'm going to project his Center
boom into the front kazushi so not here
cuz but I have some turn right then I'm
not using my hand so you could tell that
I went around the fist but you don't do
it like
that I demonstrated it with the hands
okay what I'm trying to not want you to
do is this because that's not
realistic I can't do
that so here neutral boom Jack around I
have the wrist and
elbow but I'm not using the wrist to
know neutral
y
I'm touching
them I'm touching them but I'm not using
them I'm just here here is where they
take
over as he's folling by
following
I'm not doing a wrist lock here either
that would require me to crank it and
then push it I'm not touching it I'm not
touching it and it'll
work up
in I took them out to show a point
you're taking them out because your May
is wrong and they don't
fit try it
again so energetically kadori is testing
that your C can fill all of your body
and maintain positional
organization why because the corners are
the weak point you can't hold the
corners you just you can't hold the
center it's a yinyang world you don't
have a center if you don't don't have
corners you got to have periphery to
have the center okay but that means they
have to be in relationship with each
other like orbiting Bodies In
Space you can't just have corners and
they do whatever then you don't have a
center so kadori energetically is
cultivating Corner Integrity by which I
mean Center
Integrity however
martially you should not try to
overpower
people okay so if you pay
attention I I'm not concerned with
his arm on
me checking over the top can't come into
my face and I'll take that tradeoff
every time all I have to deal with now
is his linear energy that's
it now I
project well again I'm just showing you
that I'm not using my hands to do any of
this and if I move around this hand by
correctly Ed
me I'm on the other side of that
grip he also is remaining his hold on me
cuz I've never challenged it so if I see
somebody's hand that came
off long before I would say about here
it's cuz you pulled it off and you
challenged
it which is unrealistic and you stopped
your corner
training so one boom is it doesn't come
off do you see till his shoulder goes
there it is right there this is about
I'm he's barely hanging on
there and that is entirely
different from this do you see this is
La La Land This is not training your
corner even if you get over here boom
and you come around that too is the same
fantasy L you understand so I would
rather you task yourself with not uh
having him come off just falls off and
I'm following him falling do you
see
[Music]
I didn't pull the hand down I didn't
push the elbow down okay see how long
you can keep his grip long there go